150 ans après le Moyen Âge, en 1560, une
nouvelle campagne de grands travaux
est sur le point d'être lancée à Chantilly,
à la demande du nouveau maître des lieux,
un certain Anne de Montmorency.
- Anne, ici, est un prénom masculin.
C'est un peu déroutant pour nous,
mais c'est bien un homme.
Et cet homme n'est pas n'importe qui.
C'est l'une des personnes les plus puissantes
de France au XVIᵉ siècle. Il est connétable,
autrement dit le chef suprême des armées,
et il est immensément riche.
- Anne de Montmorency était propriétaire
de 600 fiefs et de 130 châteaux
et seigneuries, plus des hôtels particuliers
dans Paris, et on sait qu'il était
très féru d'architecture.
- Ce personnage essentiel qui va avoir des
possessions dans toute la France, va faire
de Chantilly sa principale résidence.
Et ça va être un tournant pour l'histoire
de Chantilly, vraiment. Avec des chantiers
immenses qui vont être menés.
Des chantiers qui vont très vite devenir un
casse-tête pour les ouvriers. Car après avoir
ajouté des fenêtres à la forteresse médiévale,
le commanditaire veut l'agrandir pour recevoir
les plus grands rois de France et d'Europe.
- La Cour de France qui se déploie, c'est
plusieurs milliers de personnes qui bougent.
- On trouve que le château est un peu petit,
on veut l'agrandir, mais on est assez
contraint par les 7 tours et la forme
triangulaire.
- On va avoir sans arrêt à Chantilly le besoin
de trouver de l'espace.
Et ce n'est pas le seul problème que pose la
forteresse médiévale. Le connétable veut
également que son château respecte les codes
architecturaux de la Renaissance.
À l'époque, les nouvelles constructions
arborent une architecture parfaitement
symétrique, comme ici à Chambord.
Tout le contraire de Chantilly.
- C'est vraiment une disposition qui a,
selon les mots des hommes de la Renaissance,
une sauvage quadrature. Donc il n'y a pas
d'angle droit. C'est complètement bizarre.
- Sur ce rocher, il était très compliqué
de faire quoi que ce soit de symétrique.
Pour satisfaire les exigences du
commanditaire, les ouvriers vont réaliser
un véritable tour de force. Ils décident
de construire une extension sur l'eau,
un petit château en avant de la forteresse,
qui servira de hall d'entrée majestueux
pour les invités. Et pour réaliser cet
incroyable défi de construire sur l'eau,
ils vont s'inspirer de la plus grande
ville flottante au monde.
- Ils ont construit le petit château de la
même façon qui a été construit la ville de
Venise. Ils ont enfoncé des piliers en bois
dans la boue, sous l'eau.
- On va remettre en place ce qu'on appelle
parfois des sonnettes ou des moutons qui sont
des sortes de grands poids. On va faire
descendre régulièrement sur le pieu
et tant que le pieux descend,
on continue à l'enfoncer.
Une méthode qui nécessite plusieurs
précautions techniques, sous peine
de voir la structure s'écrouler.
- Il faut que les pilotis soient toujours
sous l'eau. La règle d'or, c'est celle-là.
S'ils sont en dehors de l'eau, il y a
une zone de contact et de pourrissement
qui peut se faire. Donc il faut qu'ils soient
toujours noyés dans l'eau. Et par dessus,
on fait ce qu'on appelle un radier,
c'est-à-dire des poutres croisées,
et on met des maçonneries qui vont servir
de support à la construction elle-même.
Grâce à ce système de pilotis, des dizaines
de mètres vont pouvoir être gagnés sur l'eau.